[Musique]
une trappe est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
seul un français sur quatre fait
confiance au gouvernement face au
terrorisme
une chute de 18 points du baromètre
sécurité depuis cet été alors que la
france est passé en alerte urgence
attentats l'exécutif a tenu un conseil
de défense il a lancé un appel à la
vigilance à ses ressortissants alors que
des manifestations se poursuivent dans
des pays arabo musulmans
la france de nouveau assignée à
résidence pour au moins un mois ce pour
les élèves à partir de lundi et encore
les professeurs ont décidé de faire
grève
lorsque le télétravail est impossible
également des indicateurs toujours à la
hausse et des essais de médicaments et
de vaccins suspendu à cause des
surmortalités constater l'état d'urgence
sanitaire lui a été écourté de deux
semaines par le sénat
et à la veille de l'élection
présidentielle contestée en côte
d'ivoire l'ancien président laurent
gbagbo s'exprime pour la première fois
depuis dix ans il condamne le troisième
mandat brillé par son ancien rival
alassane ouattara et appelle au dialogue
alors que le convoi du secrétaire
général de la présidence a été mitraillé
alarmes automatiques qui hier soir au
nord d'abidjan
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce vendredi le
recueillement à nice au lendemain de
l'attaqué au couteau qui a fait trois
morts malgré le confinement des dizaines
de personnes se sont rendues devant la
basilique notre dame de l'assomption
pour y déposer des fleurs ou des bougies
en hommage aux trois victimes un
sacristain de la paroisse une mère
célibataire brésilienne et une
sexagénaire fidèles de cette église
voyez les précisions sur place de notre
reporter madej abderrazak colère
tristesse c'est sidération voilà 3d
sentiment qui prime
à nice au lendemain de l'attaqué
perpétrée dans la basilique notre dame
de l'ascension qui se trouve derrière
moi attaque au couteau qui a coûté la
vie à trois personnes
plusieurs membres des différentes
communautés religieuses locales se sont
succédé tout au long de la journée pour
rendre hommage aux victimes pour
promouvoir le vivre ensemble et le
dialogue interreligieux a parmi eux
figurent l gil florini curé doyen de
nice malgré les circonstances il appelle
à l'unité et au rassemblement
bah c'est un sentiment de
d'incompréhension et d'injustice parce
que effectivement les chrétiens emploi
n'y sont pour rien mais vu de
l'extérieur
la france est un pays chrétien mais se
trompe beaucoup mais c'est comme ça que
les gens pensent à l'extérieur et ceux
qui ne savent pas c'est que les
chrétiens en général et les catholiques
en particulier sont bien plus souvent
caricaturé entre dans charlie hebdo que
les musulmans je veux dire si vous
regardez les dix dernières années il y
en a beaucoup plus contre le pape les
curés les pédophiles tout ce que vous
voulez que quand les musulmans mais
voilà ils ne prennent que la partie qui
les intéressent et surtout certains ne
se servent que de la partie qui excite
les plus fanatiques parce que c'est ça
aussi je ne pense pas que le fait d'être
musulman soit suffisant je pense qu'ils
sont aussi fanatiques et c'est ça le
drame quoi avoir peur non parce que
malheureusement
si ça arrive ça arrive et on n'y peut
rien ces trois personnes qui ont été
tuées
je n'avais rien fait de spécial et c'est
juste là au mauvais moment quoi voilà
donc ça il faut pas non plus vivre dans
la peur il ya déjà assez de peur à cause
d'autres raisons à cause des virus à
cause d'autres attendent un que c'est
pas la peine d'en rajouter à la douane
l'étude mais pas mais pas de peur
depuis hier c'est le choc dans la cité
azuréenne est les niçois sont en deuil
c'est la troisième fois depuis 2015 que
leur ville est touchée par le terrorisme
des niçois très attristé de voir une
nouvelle attaque se dérouler sur leurs
terres mais qui ne veulent pas pour
autant céder à la panique à plusieurs
d'entre eux chrétien juif musulman ou
encore athées ont fait le déplacement
pour rendre un dernier hommage aux
victimes pour soutenir la communauté
chrétienne victime cible de cet attentat
donc on voit là des niçois qui continue
de se mobiliser encore ce soir en vous
le voyez est derrière moi malgré lé
mesures de confinement est liée à la
crise sanitaire beaucoup ont tenu à se
déplacer pour et bien allumé une bougie
ou encore déposé des fleurs vous l'aurez
compris et l'émotion est encore très
présente ce soir
et puis sachez qu'un homme de 47 ans est
en garde à vue depuis hier soir n'est
soupçonné d'avoir été en contact avec le
terroriste l'assaillant lui est toujours
hospitalisé dans un état grave il
s'appelle brahima issaoui un tunisien
issu d'une famille modeste de sfax
il aurait appelé sa famille avant
l'attentât ses proches affirment qu'il
s'est tourné vers la religion il y a
deux ans et coûté son frère ça ne fait
pas un mois et demi un mois et 2 jours
qu'il a fait la traversée il est arrivé
en france mercredi dernier aux alentours
de 20 heures
il a dit qu'il allait en france car pour
le travail c'est mieux et en italie il
ya trop de monde
comme j'ai dit nous a téléphoné mercredi
dernier ils étaient arrivés en france
vers 20h 21h c'est tout ce qu'on sait et
voyez à présent ce que dit nicolas
vincent secrétaire départemental adjoint
du syndicat de police alliance dans les
alpes maritimes un manque cruel de
personnel dit-il écouter le confinement
j'ai envie de dire ça aurait pu arranger
les choses
sachant que beaucoup de monde doit
rester à son domicile
mais malgré tous mes collègues sont
engagés sur ce confinement comme il
l'était au moins de mars
parce qu'il ya des contrôles confinement
il y en a encore qui respectent pas
cette crise sanitaire et qui puisait
depuis hier l'urgence attentats et ce
qui s'est passé à nice va être encore
plus comment dire
gênant et surtout prendre l'attention de
mes collègues sur le terrain pour
justement surveillé alors en ce qui
concerne les lieux à surveiller j'ai
envie de dire tous les lieux sont à
surveiller
mais particulièrement les lieux de culte
vu ce qui s'est passé hier ce qui nous
manque en particulier dans les alpes
maritimes c'est ce qu'on a dit hier au
président macron les 60 effectifs arrivé
à nice au mois de septembre qui est
annoncé comme des renforts niçois nous
on sert en tant que syndicat responsable
que ce n'est pas le cas puisque depuis
des années et particulièrement cette
année on a eu plus de départs que
d'arrivées malgré ses 60 arrivées
supplémentaires annoncés donc tous les
services de police du département que ce
soit nice au niveau de la de la police
judiciaire ou de la sécurité publique et
les circonscription des alpes-maritimes
son déficit d'effectifs et à paris l'
exécutif s'est réuni en conseil de
défense à l'elysée ce matin est la
france qui est repassé en alerte urgence
attentat avec un report sans un
renforcement du plan de sécurité
vigipirate
le nombre de soldats patrouillant dans
les rues va passer de 3000 à 7000
militaires
pour le ministre des affaires étrangères
je cite la menace est partout écoutez le
nous avons décidé de prendre toutes les
mesures pour assurer la sécurité de nos
intérêts de nos ressortissants et des
instructions ont été données à nos
ambassadeurs pour qu'il renforce les
dispositifs de sécurité
que ce soit les emprises n'est que ce
soit aussi les présences française
identifiée comme les alliances
françaises
et nous avons aussi pris la décision de
nous autoriser les ouvertures
d'établissements scolaires qu'à partir
du moment où
une vigilance a été accrue et une
attention aura été portée à l'égard à la
fois des parents des enseignants et des
élèves pour que garantir la sécurité
dans ces établissements de le faisant en
relation avec des autorités locales et
nous avons lancé le message d'urgence
attentat a été envoyé hier soir à
l'ensemble de nos ressortissants à
l'étranger
quels que soient les lieux puisque la
menace elle est partout le quai d'orsay
qui appelle les français de l'étranger à
la plus grande vigilance alors que des
manifestations anti françaises
poursuivent après la promesse notamment
du chef de l'état à ne pas renoncer aux
caricatures de mahomet et à défendre la
liberté d'expression
tour d'horizon en images de ces
mobilisations à travers le monde
arabo-musulman regarder
[Applaudissements]
là
vous
ah bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
adam
mais celle de marx en faisant le même
temps il ajouté
m
[Applaudissements]
les français de nouveau appelés à rester
chez eux sauf pour aller travailler se
faire soigner ou encore faire leurs
courses
un confinement allégé par rapport à
celui du printemps dernier il s'agit de
freiner cette épidémie due coronavirus
près de 48 mille nouveaux cas vous voyez
pour 250 décès recensés ces dernières 24
heures selon le new york times la france
est le pays dans le monde qui recense
quotidiennement le plus grand nombre de
cas par million d'habitants walid
belhani explication plus qu'un lointain
souvenir
mais une nouvelle réalité rues désertes
surveillance policière retour de
l'attestation et d'une possible amende
de 135 euros
les français ont un peu plus de quatre
semaines de confinement mais
contrairement à mars et avril
l'économie ne sera pas totalement à
l'arrêt les commerces alimentaires
essentiels les stations service et les
garages les laveries et blanchisserie
les magasins de journaux et les tabacs
les opticiens certains magasins
spécialisés d'équipement informatique
les télécommunications la location de
voitures et d'équipements resteront
ouverts par rapport au confinement de
mars tous les commerces de gros les
magasins et les jardineries ainsi afin
que pardon que les professionnels
puissent continuer de s'approvisionner
les bars et restaurants ferment si leurs
portes
le gouvernement a annoncé une
indemnisation pouvant aller jusqu'à dix
mille euros par mois pour des
entreprises qui comptent jusqu'à 50
salariés
les marchés alimentaires resteront
normalement ouverts sauf décision
préfectorale
tout comme les fleuristes spécialement
le week end de la toussaint un peu plus
de liberté du côté également des
étudiants pendant le nouveau confinement
les écoles les collèges et les lycées
resteront ouvertes puisque nous l'avons
vu lors du premier confinement malgré
l'engagement de nos professeurs dans
l'enseignement à distance
nous savons que la fermeture des écoles
et des établissements entraîne
l'aggravation des retards scolaires et
nous ne voulons pas cela conformément
donc aux derniers avis du haut conseil
le masque devient obligatoire pour tous
les élèves à partir du cours
préparatoire afin que ces élèves et
leurs professeurs se prémunissent au
maximum de tout risque de contagion
hésiter éventuel un masque obligatoire
dès l'âge de 6 ans nouveauté les parents
devront se munir d'une attestation pour
conduire leurs enfants à l'école les
cours magistraux et travaux dirigés dans
les établissements supérieurs se feront
à distance se soigner travailler
s'éduquer se former priorité donc de ce
deuxième confinement généraliser les
français auront une nouvelle fois très
peu l'occasion de se divertir à
l'extérieur l'essentiel des
établissements recevant du public seront
fermés les salles de spectacle et les
cinémas les salles de sport les parcs
d'attraction les salons foires et
expositions pour un déplacement d'une
heure maximum pour faire de l'activité
physique pour prendre l'air ou pour
promener vos animaux domestiques
ces déplacements ne pourront pas
dépasser ou se faire au delà d'un rayon
d'un kilomètre du domicile
contrairement au printemps les parcs
jardins forêts plages resteront ouverts
caisse et une spirale épidémique pas
d'autre solution a martelé le premier
ministre
une nouvelle évaluation est à prévoir
dans quinze jours avec l'espoir de fêter
noël et le nouvel an en famille et dans
ce contexte l'avocat fabrice di vizio
déposent un recours au conseil d'état et
une plainte au pénal après le refus de
l' agence du médicament d'autoriser plus
largement l'hydroxyde rodkin tant prônée
par le professeur didier raoult pts et
pour en parler justement nous sommes
avec fabrice division avocat du
collectif c 19 et et associations des
victimes du comique 19 france
bonsoir fabrice di vizio merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
vous avez décidé de porter cette affaire
devant la justice vous dites qu'il ya
sans doute quelque chose qui est caché
dans cette affaire et vous dites que
l'interdiction d'utiliser l'hydroxyde
chloroquine c'est fait pour favoriser un
autre médicament qui n'est pas plus
efficace a priori est plus chère et plus
toxiques le rêve des civils alors je me
suis longuement entretenu que je pouvais
ce raout sur cette question qui donc va
saisis parce que si vous voulez il ya
deux choses là la rfm
l'agent du médicament refuse au
professeur raoul tu une recommandation
temps pouvoir d'utilisation de la
chloroquine en disant écoutez on peut
pas professeur parce que vous comprenez
un ça marche pas 2 bah c'est dangereux
c'est même très dangereux la glande
sauf que cette même agence du médicament
avait deux mois auparavant
trois mois auparavant mois de juillet
accorder une autorisation de cette
fois-ci temporaire d'utilisation
or n 18 qui lui étaient notoirement
inefficace et je vais y venir
et effectivement spécialement dangereux
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que quand la
nfl a accordé aux reds y virent
l'autorisation donc de provisoire de lui
sur le marché à date échue et les biens
deux jours plus tard le haut conseil de
santé publique lui ont offert de ces
débats qui sont publiques en allant dans
les transcriptions disait que c'était
inefficace chère et qu'aucune preuve de
l'efficacité clinique n'avait été
apportée
donc comment est-ce que la rsm a pu
accorder une autorisation avec une texte
dit une présomption forte d'efficacité
là où les experts deux jours plus tard
diront que c'est notoirement inefficace
et le professeur comme en particulier
dira que pour lui il est dur mais qu'il
faut attendre les résultats de ricoh
bruit parce que ça n'a aucune efficacité
clinique à ses yeux
qu'est ce que ça cache
qu'est ce que ça cache tous les
scandales de santé publique commence
comme ça alors pour vous c'est le juste
qu'il va devoir trancher je rappelle que
le règne des civières et distribué par
le laboratoire gilead
le juge va devoir trancher s'il ya un
lien d'intérêts entre justement l'agencé
sanitaire du médicament et ce
laboratoire gilead c'est ça le le creux
de l'histoire en 2016 le parquet de
paris a ouvert une information
judiciaire sur la d paquin qu'on a
distribués massivement parce que il ils
étaient notoires depuis 1982 depuis 1982
que la débats qui avaient des effets
théâtraux jettent sur les enfants
fassent tout comme les effets
secondaires majeurs sur les grossesses
et le parquet de paris a enquêté pour
savoir ouvert une information judiciaire
pour savoir pourquoi est ce que là mêmes
avaient été accordées qu'est-ce que ça
cachait eh bien c'est la même chose ici
le parquet de paris devrait ouvrir une
information judiciaire pour savoir
pourquoi est ce que finalement depuis le
départ la chloroquine est à ce point
décrié et pourquoi est ce que le rêve 18
vire
dont l'efficacité a été reconnu comme
nul
c'est pas moi qui le dit hein le
professeur comme dit effectivement
efficacité clinique nu l'aï dit je suis
désolée trop si dure deux jours après
que la nsm est accordé son autorisation
d'utilisation ou qu'est ce que ça cache
nous saisissons le parquet parce que
nous pensons nous craignons
qu'effectivement nous soyons au coeur
d'un scandale
j'attire votre attention sur un point
comme en expliquant nous comment
expliquer que le laboratoire gilead a
fait le chiffre d'affaires moustrou est
colossal en développant et
commercialisant un traitement dans le
cadre du coc vide alors qu'il ne marche
pas c'est ce point qu effectivement le
parquet devra trancher et juge
d'instruction devra effectivement
investiguer sur ces points d'autant
qu'au vu de ses bénéfices
quasi nul il y avait un envoi de mail
siph avec la promotion du règne des
civières et distribution gratuite même
dans ce milieu gamme en absolument est
ce que vous vous rendez compte et qu'on
est capable d'opposer aux professeurs
raout confesse raul kohan on parle de
quelqu'un parle pas tout à fait non plus
du dernier des imbéciles on parle du
quand même d'une star de l'infectiologie
de quelqu'un qui effectivement est dans
le monde entier on s'arrache les
compétences et on vient effectivement
expliqué à celui ci que la chloroquine
est dangereuse qui peut raisonnablement
venir nous expliquer que papa
chloroquine et dangereuse alors que de
l'autre il est notoire que leur m18 vire
à des effets de néphrotoxicité majeur
est effectivement relayé par la
littérature que plus personne n'ose
aujourd'hui promouvoir leur haine des
civils premier élément deuxième élément
mais quelle indécence de la part de la
nfl de venir dire que la chloroquine n'a
pas de présomption simple d'efficacité
là où le rêve d'y lire avec lui une
présomption forte d'efficacité nous
sommes dans un mensonge d'état
nous sommes dans un mensonge encore un
genre bien ça fera jamais qu'un de plus
dont il faudra effectivement déterminer
les causes le traitement à liberty
chloroquine est utilisée dire par des
pays frontaliers utilisé par des pays
d'afrique qui se rient moi j'ai
régulièrement l'appui quelques jours des
mails de professeurs de médecine
africains mais qui ne comprennent pas ce
débat effectivement ce dossier qui unit
l'église
mais pardon il est d'ailleurs toujours
utilisé par des médecins aussi là où
dans des pays où l'hydroxyde rockin est
considéré comme peu efficace ababil et
il est toujours utilisé y compris en
france d'ailleurs avec des médecins qui
témoignent de leur efficacité soit
efficacité premiers éléments mais
surtout vous avez entendu de ministre de
la santé marocain venir expliquer que
lui le dire qu'effectivement il ya une
promotion de notre équipe parce que ça
fonctionnait alors moi je sais pas si ça
fonctionne moi je suis avocat et
professeur à route effectivement lui dis
que ça fonctionne il n'est pas le seul
donc on focalise son professeur out mais
il n'est pas le seul
mais alors moi j'ai quand même une
question sylvie roxy chloroquine ne
fonctionne pas premier élément
pourquoi est ce qu'on vient dire que
c'est toxique alors qu'on sait que c'est
pas vrai c'est un médicament qui était
en vente libre
jusqu'à l'année dernière et on vient
expliquer que c'est notoirement toxiques
ça ça vient de sortir et deuxième
élément pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
accordé autant de précautions avec leur
m18 vire dont lui il quand on sait qu'il
est notoirement inefficace comment je
l'expliqué
et bien si ces questions que le parquet
auquel le parquet aura à répondre alors
j'imagine que tout est une question de
dosage de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
certaines études montrent qu un
surdosage et et est effectivement
potentiellement dangereux je voudrais
que citer la haine et c'est justement le
courrier qu'elle a envoyée au professeur
didier raoult at-elle dit chez les
patients à un stade avancé de la maladie
les manifestations cardiaques peuvent
exposer un sur-risque on voit bien que
c'est à un stade avancé or le professeur
raoul tu as toujours dit qu'il fallait
donner l'hydroxyde chloroquine en début
en début de maladie là aussi aussi
nuance l'étude remarque très juste on
s'est évertué à faire en sorte au niveau
des doses au niveau du moment où tu
donnes qu'effectivement ça ça ne marche
pas au niveau d'étude discovery il ya un
truc extrêmement intéressant discovery
était censée la grande étude qui était
censé nous expliquer si oui ou non les
occitans eurokin fonctionnel et bien
c'est ce que nous allons donner au
parquet nous avons des résultats
préliminaires dont on se garde bien de
deux voilà de donner un caractère public
en tout cas d'avoir un caractère public
sur ces derniers qui montre la bêta
préliminaires montrent que sur une
cohorte de patients
eh bien nous avions un effet sur la
mortalité et sur la durée
d'hospitalisation
évidemment ces patients auraient mérité
passe à cette corde raide hérité être
augmenté et on aurait dû confirmer ces
résultats puisqu'on était là pour ça et
bien non on a décidé qu'on allait
interrompre les c'est parce que ça ne
marchait pas et que voilà ça ne servait
à rien et que en plus c'était toxique et
c'est bien donc on voit bien qu'à un
moment donné si vous voulez on parle du
professeur raoul tu mais on focalise
l'attention qu'on ne s'arrêteront pas de
professeurs à moult ici on parle des
patients qui ont le droit de savoir si
oui ou non on les a privés et pour
quelle raison d'un
vêtements à l'efficacité démontrée
effectivement si j'en crois un certain
nombre d'études certainement contestée
par d'autres mais c'est le propre de la
science tandis que dans une autre
perspective
le rêve désir et lui contester par tout
le monde et pourtant a été a été
effectivement vous le dit accord donné
massivement a été en tout cas promu
massivement et on veut savoir pourquoi
renaud muselier qui était un ancien
médecin et président de la région sud a
écrit une lettre au vitriol au ministre
de la santé justement lorsque cette ce
médicament étaient interdits d'usagé aux
professeurs rares août le droit à la
prescription d'un médicament dont la
vente est autorisée voilà ce que défend
renaud muselier
c'est ce que vous allez défendre
également au nom à ce que je vais
défendre ce que je vais défendre c'est
très simple je vais différent je vais
défendre une différence de traitement
entre deux molécules dont l'une a généré
un chiffre d'affaires colossal du
laboratoire qui a été fait cas
bénéficier d'une aide européenne
alors que tout le monde savait qu'elle
marchait pas qu'elle bénéficiait d'une
ati en vertu d'une présomption forte ce
qui est un mensonge éhonté de l'autre
une molécule qui n'a pas d'effets
secondaires notables qui était en vente
libre jusqu'ici et dont l'efficacité est
reconnu par des médecins et non des
moindres et dans le monde entier et en
particulier en afrique
voilà alors c'est très intéressant
l'histoire des africains parce que les
africains on les méprise avec une
manière absolument redoutable ont dit
oui mais vous savez ils sont marocains
car ils sont sénégalais faut pas prendre
en compte ce qu'ils disent pas pardonné
mois après on a déjà des débris table
star de la technologie en afrique dont
on mériterait quand même un petit peu
avec mes regrets à écouter donc moi ce
que je veux savoir c'est pourquoi une
telle différence de traitement
c'est tout merci beaucoup fabrice di
vizio d'avoir répondu ce soir à nos
questions sur arte france et on termine
par l'élection présidentielle sous
tension demain en côte d'ivoire avec des
appels au boycott et à la désobéissance
civile depuis l'annnonce de la
candidature du président sortant un
troisième mandat les affrontements
intercommunautaires ont fait une
trentaine de morts dans le pays
et hier soir c'est le convoi du
secrétaire général de la présidence
ivoirienne qui a été est mitraillé
sachez aussi que l'ancien président
laurent gbagbo lui est sorti de son
silence aujourd'hui françois tyszkiewicz
carcasses de voitures calcinées magasins
pillés et incendiés
à bongouanou à 200 km au nord d'abidjan
la campagne électorale de la
présidentielle a dégénéré en
affrontements intercommunautaires des
affrontements entre les a ni groupes
ethniques majoritairement propositions
et les dioula pro alassane ouattara la
ville parce qu'il ya des conflits entre
les alliés et les troubles vont pas nous
décidons dieu la main de la femme
ils ont tout pillé aux maisons de là
cela ils ont tout pillé au moins deux
personnes sont mortes dans ces violences
survenues dans ce fief d'un des
candidats de l'opposition
pascal affi n'guessan ancien premier
ministre de l'ex-président laurent
gbagbo dont la maison a été en partie
incendié des violences constatées
également à abidjan la capitale
économique
des tensions exacerbées par l'appel au
boycott et à la désobéissance civile le
15 octobre dernier de l'opposition je
voudrais lancer au nom de la plateforme
m appel solennel à nos militants de
rester mobilisés de rester déterminés
devait rester actif dans la
désobéissance signé parce que la
désobéissance civile continue une
situation explosive poussant la mission
de la communauté des états d'afrique de
l'ouest a appelé tous les parties à
faire preuve de retenue
la mission a fermement condamné les
actes de violence et appelé kit parties
à faire preuve de maximum de retenue
la mission est forte et les autorités
compétentes a invité les forces de
sécurité à rester neutre impartial et
professionnels à l'exercice de leurs
fonctions en août et septembre dernier
des violences interethniques avaient
déjà fait une quinzaine de morts dans
plusieurs villes du pays
elle faisait suite à la candidature du
président alassane ouattara et au rejet
par le conseil constitutionnel de
quarante candidatures dont celle de l'ex
chef rebelle et ancien premier ministre
guillaume soro et de l'ancien président
laurent gbagbo
il faut qu'ils arrêtent de faire du web
un jeune chat la mort vous savez les
enquêtes
bon allez jusqu'au bout et tous ceux qui
sont responsables passeront devant les
tribunaux quel que soit le rang de la
personne dix ans après la crise post
électorale de 2010 2011 qui avaient fait
plus de 3000 morts
la crainte d'un scénario similaire est
dans toutes les têtes en côte d'ivoire
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité on se retrouve dans 30
minutes rester
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure